madame la première ministre madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues nous voici
donc réunis dans l'un de ces moments
singuliers dont l'histoire a parfois la
ruse un moment singulier est à bien des
égards inquiétant singulier d'abord car
pour la première fois depuis longtemps
le parlement trouve aujourd'hui une
centralité nouvelle le suffrage
universel notre juger notre maître à
tous madame la première ministre ne nous
a pas accordé de majorité les français
ne vous font plus confiance ils ne font
plus confiance au président de la
république et ne veulent pas de son
programme vous avez perdu le président
absolue en même temps que vous perdiez
la majorité absolue les électeurs ont
donc fait le choix d'une minorité
présidentielle et d'un parlementarisme
de fait le coeur du pouvoir a quitté le
palais de l'elysée pour prendre place
ici au palais bourbon
inquiétant ensuite car cette assemblée
est la plus mal élue de son histoire sa
légitimité mise à mal par la même
raymond tente de l'abstention symptôme
d'une démocratie fatiguée et d'électeurs
qui ne croient plus en leurs
représentants
inquiétant surtout avec l'entrée en
nombre d' une extrême droite dont vous
aviez promis d'être le rempart et au
lieu de cela nous avons entendu dans vos
rangs même se fissurer le front
républicain sur vous quand même facilité
l'élection de deux vice présidents du
rassemblement national la fébrilité
n'excusent ni de perdre son sang froid
ni ses principes républicains je le dis
pour nous il n'y a rien à espérer du
désespoir et l'extrême droite est une
funeste impasse dans cette assemblée
comme socialiste comme républicains nous
serviront toujours une autre idée de la
france madame la première ministre ne
nous vous rejoindront pas pour mettre en
oeuvre un programme et un projet
libéraux qui ne sont pas les nôtres et
pour lesquels les électeurs ne nous ont
pas désigné nous sommes opposés durant
cinq ans à la baisse des appels à
l'abandon de la sf et à l'institution de
la flat tax et nous avons plaidé pour
une lutte déterminée contre les
inégalités que vous n'avez en définitive
jamais menée nous avons combattu votre
réforme de l'assurance-chômage violente
avec les plus précaires
du logement social désastreuses pour les
bailleurs sociaux comme as tu encore
votre première réforme des retraites
injuste aux métiers pénibles nous avons
dénoncé les insuffisances de votre
engagement en faveur de l'environnement
qui vous a valu d'être condamné pour une
action climatique nous avons dénoncé le
malthusianisme de votre politique
éducative d'idées non par l'ambition de
donner une place à chacun mais par le
souci que chacun reste à sa place
nous sommes des solidarités et d'autres
politiques en matière d'asile et
d'immigration et avant contester les
lois qui portait une atteinte excessive
à nos droits et nos libertés à chaque
fois à chaque fois nous avons proposé à
chaque fois vous vous êtes obstiné
madame la première ministre convenait
avec nous nous n'avons pas été élus pour
donner au président de la république la
majorité que les françaises lui ont
refusé moins encore pour mettre en
oeuvre la retraite à 65 ans les
contreparties au rsa ou la libérer elle
gestion de l'école publique
13 millions de français sont en
situation de précarité de mobilité 12
millions habitent dans des passoires
énergétiques 10 millions vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté 8 millions vivent dans
un désert médical 6 millions demeure
sans emploi stable trois cent mille sont
sans domicile fixe et 20% de nos
compatriotes vivent à découvert la
température augmente en même temps que
la bio diversité s'effondre et nous
avons touché les limites du monde tel
qu'il a prévalu aujourd'hui menacé par
l'injustice et la démesure et en
définitive par la précarité économique
sociale écologique où nous a entraînés
l'ère néolibérale
vous aspirez un retour à la normale nous
aspirons un changement de modèle à
l'aube d'une décennie critique nous
avons des propositions utiles à la vie
des françaises et des français et nous
sommes prêts à en débattre ici notre
projet ne nous appartient pas l'idéal
qu'il entend porter est à la portée de
tous chaque fois que vous élevez vous
élèverez le débat pour atteindre l'idéal
de justice vous nous trouverez à vos
côtés vous affirmez
que les oppositions s'oppose à tout
alors apprenez à écouter à considérer
leur proposition est parfois allé faire
vôtre nous défendons le travail de
valeur et la reconnaissance de l'utilité
sociale chacun doit pouvoir vivre de la
dignité de son travail un travail de
qualité justement rémunérés notre
philosophie n'est pas celles des chèques
et occasionnels et des primes qui ne
crée pas de droits sociaux mais celle
des salaires qui permettent de vivre de
son travail est de préparer sa retraite
du juste partage de la valeur ajoutée
voilà pourquoi nous proposons le smic à
1500 euros et la limitation des écarts
de rémunération
nous proposons une plus grande justice
fiscale pour que les classes moyennes
cesse de payer les impôts des riches que
vous avez exonéré dsf pour que les pme
et les pmi chaise de payer les impôts
que les multinationales cache dans les
paradis fiscaux
nous proposons l'ouverture des droits
sociaux à 18 ans comme par tout en
europe car nous ne voulons plus voir
notre jeunesse grossir les rangs des
banques alimentaires
jaurès disait que la république est un
grand acte de conscience de confiance eh
bien faisons confiance à notre jeunesse
nul besoin de la placer sous la tutelle
du ministère de la défense comme vous le
proposez aujourd'hui
nous proposons une politique écologique
et sociale du logement et la
massification de la rénovation thermique
de logements pour sortir en disant les
français de la précarité énergétique une
écologie populaire planifié plutôt que
l'effondrement brutal pour permettre aux
français de mieux vivre de bien se loger
de mieux se nourrir de mieux se déplacer
depuis eux habitent et nous défendrons
la république jusqu'au bout celle de
jaurès celle des services publics nous
défendons l'accès aux soins par
l'obligation d'installation des médecins
par la différence de l'hôpital nous
défendons l'accès à l'éducation par la
mixité scolaire que vous n'avez jamais
défendu ses propos ils sont combien
d'autres nous avons formulé elles sont
aujourd'hui sur la table c'est le sens
de la proposition pour le pouvoir
d'achat que nous avons déposé avec la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale
il va vous falloir écouter entendre
renoncer à beaucoup de vos projets alors
que je vous paraissez d'avoir renoncé à
rien à partager aussi le pouvoir pour
l'exercer à faire vivre ce parlement
président du groupe socialiste et
apparentés je suis le dépositaire d'une
grande famille celle du socialisme qui
siège sur ses bancs de l'assemblée
nationale depuis 129 en or en me
retournant sur cette histoire je
constate que certains des grands combats
qu'on menait le socialisme et qui font
désormais partie de notre histoire
commune l'ont été alors que les
socialistes ne disposez pas de majorité
je prendrai deux exemples le début de la
4è république à quelques titres de
gloire l'application du programme du cnr
la fermeture du bagne de cayenne la
nationalisation des banques et des
industries de l'énergie le retour à la
semaine de 40 heures la généralisation
de la sécurité sociale or ce fut une
majorité allant de la démocratie
chrétienne jusqu aux communistes en
passant par les socialistes qui présida
à cette oeuvre une majorité qui donna sa
confiance aussi bien un socialiste comme
félix gouin qu'un démocrate chrétien
comme georges bidault mon deuxième
exemple remonte à la fin du 19ème d'une
troisième république fatigué ou se
succéder les scandales et les affaires
jusqu'au plus grand péril la sphère
dreyfus la république était en danger en
1899 après une énième provocation
nationaliste au plus fort de la crise le
gouvernement waldeck-rousseau obtient la
confiance d'une large à partie de
l'assemblée qui allait du centre droit
jusqu aux troupes de jaurès or ce
gouvernement sera le plus long de la
troisième république c'est celui qui
mettra fin à l affaire dreyfus c'est
celui qui entravera le travail des
femmes et des enfants celui qui
permettra le loi d'assaut sur les
associations la syndicalisation des
fonctionnaires et c'est toujours avec le
soutien de la gauche et les socialistes
que cette assemblée vota l'immortel
séparation des églises et de l'état
vous le voyez si j'osais je dirais que
la république ce que la république a
réalisé de plus glorieux elle l'a fait
dans la diversité des formations
politiques je veux m'adresser
aux députés du rassemblement national un
instant l'histoire glorieuse que je
rappelle ici n'est pas la vôtre
ce dont vous êtes les héritiers n'était
pas dans les murs de cette enceinte en
1946 je nous dira je n'ose dire où ils
étaient pour la plupart ce dont vous
êtes les héritiers était en revanche sur
le banc des accusés de zola ce que la
france a fait de grands dans son
histoire elle l'a fait le plus souvent
sans vous et le plus souvent elle l'a
fait contre vous
venons en madame la première ministre à
ce parlementarisme de fait
madame la première ministre partage et
la maîtrise de l'ordre du jour en
mettant l'agenda législatif de votre
gouvernement
au sein de la conférence des présidents
d'assemblée nationale
rééquilibrer l'initiative de la loi en
intégrant dans votre agenda
les propositions parlementaires en
particulier celle des oppositions à nous
de les défendre desserrer l'étreinte du
temps sur les travaux parlementaires en
allongeant de quelques semaines le délai
entre le dépôt de vos textes et le
moment où on en discutera laisser le
temps à des travaux préparatoires de
qualité à des délibérations sincère à la
recherche de l'intérêt général retenez
vous d'utiliser les procédures d'urgence
et les ordonnances fait cela madame la
ministre changer quitte à légiférer un
peu moins et chers collègues pas
pratique on différemment notre mandat
répartissons mieux la fonction de
rapporteur de nos travaux entre nous
exigions de celle d'aider ceux qui
exerceront ce travail de concertation de
travailler avec tous les groupes
investissent l'ont pleinement la
fonction de rapporteur d'applications
pour juger de la qualité des études
d'impact donnons ainsi une utilité aux
contributions citoyennes déposés à
l'occasion de celle ci un journaliste et
festif partagé initiative législative et
4k équilibré merci beaucoup je termine
terme et temps législatif
exercice nouveau des fonctions de
rapporteur socialiste de gauche nous
demeurons votre position n'est d'accord
sont nombreux profond nous défendrons à
ce n'est pas la justice et l'égalité je
termine non merci mr mat arrive enfin
même si mais c'est la même règle pour
tout le monde le tube halo c'est
simplement la même règle pour tout le
monde